[Music]
this morning and in this afternoon you
heard about some of the department
faculty who actually left to join
industry and had a major impact in
industry today we have an example of a
very distinguished alumnus who made his
mark in industry has finally seen the
lightning and has become a scholar and
is enjoying a second career as a
professor and that's Ralph Landau who
all of you I think know Ralph is going
to talk to us about the role of chemical
engineering in the growth of the
chemical process industries Ralph
good afternoon and ladies and gentlemen
it's a big honor to be here with you I
hope I won't let you down after the
brilliant in performances this morning
but I should say when skips Griffin
talked about chemical engineering in the
old days it said that the first
curriculum was in 1888 at MIT in the
second one at Penn in 1892 that the
Institute was founded in 1908 I should
do what President Reagan sometimes says
I remember those days well since I went
to Penn was born in Philadelphia and
then at MIT my title had and the printed
text the word catalyst for the chemical
process industries and Clark quite
correctly pointed out that a catalyst is
not supposed to be changed in the course
of a reaction and therefore it's
inappropriate for the title I quite
agree with him he gave me the title and
I didn't have the sense that resistant
so the truth is Chemical Engineering and
its role in the chemical process
industries had a very substantial
interaction and each change the other
over the years as I will attempt to
present in the next 35 to 40 minutes and
I have a special dispensation to run
over a half hour simply because I said I
have to do it but that's that's how it
is now that I'm an academic I'm learning
how to fill 50 minutes very well but not
quite anyway I want to paint the picture
of Chemical Engineering and the industry
with which it has been associated for so
long in his economic context because
obviously what make em achill
engineering awry arise out of chemistry
and develop its own character was its
economic context and I will try to paint
that economic context as we go along and
the different eras that I wish to
summarize this is based on a work that
I'm still doing at Stanford and is
therefore a short summary of a work in
progress which I hope will become a more
extensive work as we get further into
the into the analysis of our very fine
the industry let me just very briefly
touch on chemical engineering in the
period from the 1888 initiation until
1920 and describe it in the following
short sentences that the first course in
1988 as you heard earlier was
descriptive industrial chemistry mostly
inorganic industrial companies alone and
those here and I tiara possess the
know-how to design and operate
large-scale plants and MIT was still an
undergraduate engineering school when
Arthur noise in 1903 saw to convert MIT
into a science-based University
including a graduate school oriented
toward basic research he felt they would
also better train young people for
careers in industry but William Walker
also a chemistry professor had a
different vision and emphasized that it
should remain a school of engineering
technology and trained the builders and
leaders of Industry by focusing on
Applied Sciences in his view learning at
physical science principles was not
enough understanding of large scale
problems drawn from industry was
essential
so Walker reorganized the program in
industrial chemistry which was
languishing but he came converting its
heterogeneous collection of courses into
a unified program based on like
chemistry on a study of unit operations
which reduced the vast number of
industrial chemical processes to the
analysis of a few basic steps such as
you heard distillation heat transfer
filtration and the Lightning Walker who
also founded the AIChE as you heard in
1908 established the research laboratory
of applied chemistry in nineteen and a
and and saying in 1908 to obtain
research contracts with industrial firms
and to serve as the basis for graduate
students in chemical engineering and
this year a few firms had their own
research facilities where as the rapid
growth of the German chemical industry
was due to close cooperation between
University and academics to further the
industrial linkage Walker and his
younger colleague Corinth Kay Lewis
founded the school of chemical
engineering practice helped by Arthur D
little this gave students access to the
expensive industrial facilities required
to relate classroom instruction and unit
operations to industrial practices but
under the supervision
a faculty member these two viewpoints of
noise and Walker never proved
reconcilable by the end of World War one
noises influence in the chemistry
department slipped while workers program
and chemical engineering grew in
popularity and in students the rapid
expansion of the undergraduate chemical
engineering program at that time
paralleled and derived from the rapid
expansion of the American chemical
industry resulting from the war and the
loss of German chemical imports this
linkage of the industry and the
profession has been pervasive ever since
by the end of 1919 therefore noise
resigned and as you heard earlier went
to California Institute of Technology
and organize and help them create the
modern Institute it's interesting to
note that William Walker who resigned
shortly thereafter left his mark at MIT
and a much in a different path
altogether
I happen to be a privileged person in
that I'm a trustee of both Caltech and
MIT and the different visions of noise
and Walker still persist to a
considerable degree to this day Caltech
is more of a science-based University
and MIT is more of an engineering based
University although there are many
exceptions to that general statement but
the time Walker seemed to be in the
ascendancy there was however opposition
and other faculties at MIT to his
aggressiveness and reliance on
industrial ties and he got into real
difficulty in securing adequate funds
for the r-la see especially as a result
of the post-war recession that came in
about 1919 1920 and therefore the
selectivity in choosing problems
diminished Walker then frustrated and
resigned but left a legacy of industrial
linkage for chemical engineering
education now let me trace Chemical
Engineering and petroleum refining in
the area of 1920 to 1941 Warren Lewis
inherited the research laboratory of
apply chemistry of course and its
difficulties finances and short-term
projects while arising from industrial
problems chemical engineering
researchers there were often led to the
not immediately practicable but having a
perspective over a longer term Louis
thus moved to quantify and extend the
knowledge of the fundamental unit
operations the chemical engineering
department became an intellectually
powerful Center during this period and
the pioneer text of the principles of
chemical engineering appeared in 1923
simultaneously with Admiral as you heard
at the same time Luers developed a new
relation with the petroleum refining
industry which had an enormous impact on
the chemical process industries the oil
companies of that era foresaw the
gasoline demand for mass-produced cars
with boom after the war they needed to
develop and install large scale improve
continuous processes now amico then
standard of Indiana a large refiner had
developed the Burton Humphries thermal
cracking process which was a batch
process suffering carbon deposits that
require periodic shutdowns for burn out
Exxon revised this to the Toobin tank
process and hired Frank a Howard from
Indiana as head of its newly development
department almost the first thing Howard
did was to engage the best consultant
around and that was Warren K Lewis a
partnership was formed that would have a
profound influence on Exxon and on
chemical engineering Lewis's first
efforts were to provide precision
distillation and to make the process
continuous and automatic but processes
were clearly inadequate for the rising
market demand for gasoline by 1924 Lewis
helped increase oil recovery by the use
of vacuum stills
his designs became refinery standards
and coursework at MIT change to embody
these new design concepts by 1927 Howard
began a series of agreements with the
German IG Farben gaining access to their
work on hydrogenation and synthetic
substitutes for oil and rubber from coal
Howard needed a whole new research group
to handle this new technology
particularly knowledgeable about
chemical process technology again he
consulted Louis and who in turn
introduced to him Robert Haslam whose
name you heard earlier from Lloyd Hottel
who was then the head of the chemical
engineering practice school has them
formed a team of 15 MIT graduates who
set up a research organization at Baton
Rouge headed by Haslam himself
of those 15 those pioneers one is with
us today and that is bud Fischer and a
bud is the audience I
we will give them a big hand because
he's a survivor
six of these 15 rows to high office and
members of Exxon's board haslam himself
became vice president in 1927 of the
development department and a senior
officer of the SL company before he
retired another staffer of the URL AC
was re Wilson who as you heard earlier
the day became chairman and CEO of amico
Exxon during this period closely linked
apply the innovative research including
the application of chemical catalysis
much of modern petroleum refining
originated in Baton Rouge and it was
basically an MIT chemical engineering
group that got it going with a
continuing advice of Louis and later in
1935 of Ed Gilliland Baton Rouge
produced such outstanding process
developments as hydroforming fluid cat
cracking and fluid flex coking and Hoyt
huddle had also started consulting with
Exxon on problems and combustion which
became reflected in hovels longtime
influence and teaching combustion theory
and practice the slowest created a very
different approach from Walker's instead
of bringing industry to the campus as in
the RL AC he brought the campus to
industry unlike the practice school
which also did this he helped solve the
big problems of Industry and so he
established modern chemical engineering
education proving that industrial
consultation by professors enriched the
employers and the Institute's
educational program he created the
precedent that able MIT faculty and
students should go in the industry and
move it along providing valuable
experience in buy and return and
potential funding for MIT Ken Jamison
the chairman of Exxon was the man in
charge of the drive it got us our new
chemical engineering building three
lowest focused chemical engineering on
the design of continuous automated
processing of a huge variety of products
first in petroleum refining and then in
chemicals other chemical engineering
departments as well as mi t--'s flourish
that attracted the brightest students
from all over the United States and
abroad who in turn moved into high
positions throughout the petroleum and
chemical industries other engineering
disciplines lacking this history of
direct involvement with a major a
growing industry never developed such an
overall systems approach the
design of continuously operating
production planes with the exception of
the electric power industry now I'd like
I would like to deviate a little bit and
talk about the role of the process
design firms in the early part of this
century up until 1941 a little-known
aspect of the rise of chemical
engineering as a design discipline has
long resided in the engineering design
firms which contained all the skills
necessary to build complete process
plants particularly in refining and
chemicals the most prominent emerged
early in this century
UOP was more research oriented in its
approach to petroleum refining and
became the major source of process
technologies for the smaller oil
companies MW Kellogg grew as a partner
with some of the majors in the
development of the fluid catalytic
cracking process Hydra forming and so on
few oil companies had the complete
organization necessary in those days to
perform all the phases of plant design
and construction because of the obvious
need for designer continuous
automatically controlled units these and
other similar companies soon came to be
dominated by chemical engineers many
trained by MIT now briefly tracked the
history of the chemical industry before
1941 although this is a very skeleton
approach a few key features firstly the
first world war proved to the United
States that it must become more
self-sufficient than all important
chemicals and the number of companies
and products grew secondly in the
Depression a world cartel and the major
chemical sorrows entry costs for new
company were prohibitive the industry
survived 3 the industry was largely
based on branch operations and the
chemical engineer was not yet perceived
as a critical resource and fourth
nevertheless companies like Exxon Union
Carbide shell and Dow ventured into what
were the first small-scale stages of the
rise of the petrochemical industry
detailed in the excellent book on
petrochemicals by my former colleague
Peter H Spitz who I think is also here
today here the need for chemical
engineering skills rose sharply as the
scale of operations forced resort to
continuous processing as previously in
the petroleum refining industry and
chemical raw materials began their
ethical shift from coal base to
petroleum-based the war years again can
only be summarized in a few
paragraphs the United States had entered
a crash program to build many new
facilities for synthetic rubber
petroleum refining chemicals munitions
light metals etc much sharing of
know-how and processes between
competitors took place many new
companies undertook chemical
manufacturing and personnel were widely
interchanged engineering design firms
were swamped with orders becoming an
important reservoir of wive widely
experienced chemical engineers and as
the war ended the government insisted on
selling the new plants to many newcomers
and competitors of the traditional
chemical industry the European chemical
industry lay in ruins and the pre-war
cartel had ceased to exist that was the
picture at 1946
now I'll trace the two decades from 46
to 66 which I call the stable decades
and I will first talk about the broader
economic climate in which our industry
developed and then I'll narrow the focus
to the chemical industry itself and I
should say at this point a nice talk
about the chemical industry I'm talking
about what the Department of Commerce
used to call standard Industrial
Classification number 28 it's a very
broad industry a lot of different
segments and while I'm speaking in the
overall industry the separate parts of
it had very different histories and
different characteristics it's not time
that in this talk to give you a better
picture of how widely divergent some of
these parts were anyway during that
period of 46 to 66 the United States had
a unique world situation there was a
large pent-up domestic demand the need
for reconstruction abroad United States
were the only center of undamaged and
new industrial facilities and finances
and had little competition
the United States government maintained
a low inflation low interest economy
with low cost of capital federal budgets
were close to balance and there was a
positive trade balance overall despite
the Korean War the economic climate was
favorable for growth the post-war real
growth rate and GNP real terms reached
historic highs averaging around three
and a half percent per year productivity
growth was also good in this period
averaging two and a half percent per
capita in real terms until 1973 this
favorable world scene obviously greatly
influenced
the progress of the chemical industry
firstly became international very
quickly secondly the entry costs were
low competitive scale of plants was
still small capital costs were low
building times rapid and markets almost
continually expanding thirdly technology
spread rapidly around the world
licensing by domestic producers and
process design firms accelerated while
important foreign inventions such as
Ziegler's polyethylene not as
polypropylene and icy eyes polyester
fiber and high pressure polyethylene
crossed the ocean to here licensing
became an apparently profitable
technique for companies unable to invest
everywhere to earn additional revenue
fourthly American chemical engineering
developing rapidly in our universities
proved to have an overwhelming
competitive advantage abroad where there
were smaller and less diversified
refineries and chemical plants that have
been largely designed by chemists unused
to large scale herbs fifthly chemical
engineers rose to top management
positions in oil and chemical companies
thus by this process innovation was
coupled to the marketplace and process
design integrative of the product
sixthly the growth and petroleum
feedstocks for the chemical industry
attracted the attention of the oil
companies who sought forward integration
while chemical companies looked for ways
to integrate backwards seventh there was
a flow of new products such as synthetic
fibers plastics and detergents into the
marketplace many of these were superior
substitutes of novel applications of
synthetic products for such fibers as
cotton wool and silk as well as plastics
for paper glass and wood 8 there was a
lack of pervasive intrusion by
government in a variety of areas 9th the
chemical trade balance remained positive
a combination of strong innovation
favorable raw materials some tariff
protection and the need to maintain a
competitive edge against the rapidly
reviving European chemical giants which
sharpen management skills 10th
although profits of u.s. chemical
producers grew rapidly in the mid 50's
so did those of other basic industries
by the end of the 1950's the exuberant
expansion of the industry led to over
building and over capacity nevertheless
the earnings of the industry grew about
as fast as
Manufacturing up until 1966 but the
balance sheets were deteriorating the
signs of competitive pressure both
domestic and international were
unmistakable
unlike electronics and computers where
many small companies did much innovating
chemical did not have this entry costs
from already too high as I attempted
briefly to say earlier with this kind of
favorable stable climate many product
lines and processes appeared among the
many innovators were the presses design
oriented engineering firms described
above previously which were basically
responsible for developing
commercializing the key processes for
petrochemical raw materials manufacture
these were ethylene cracking and
distillation processes primarily by
Lummis Kellogg foster wheeler stone and
Webster at aromatics extraction and
production by UOP in the platforming
process you Dex and the like the modern
petrochemical industry would be
inconceivable without these fundamental
American Chemical Engineering
developments and they spread rapidly
around the world to make petroleum and
other hydrocarbon feedstocks the primary
raw material source for the chemical
industry but this also opened the door
to many new and vigorous competitors to
American firms I've left out a lot of
detail about other engineering firms
like my own and I think there's a paper
in your and your booklet you got bitched
I described some more detail about what
we were doing every day and therefore I
can only say at this point that in
following doc Lewis's concept of
chemical engineering applied the
creative process design I started our
company in 46 with that basic model in
mind I wrote about this in the paper I
described and we have always searched
even though a license widely for
manufacture position rather than in
licensing first in ethylene oxide in the
late 40s then in terephthalic acid in
the mid 50s which we sold amico and
finally successfully in the mid 60s with
our propylene oxide process would form
the basis for our ox rain joint venture
with our car during this period we saw
for ourselves how powerful were the
tools of American Chemical Engineering
by bringing this discipline to West
Germany their design methods were
clearly unsuited to the
larger-scale of the modern petrochemical
industry well we built our first
ethylene oxide plant during the middle
50s for major German chemical company it
was size at 4,000 tons per year a number
that I find inconceivable today
soon after completion they wanted to
quadruple the capacity to 16,000 tons
per year we offered them a design for a
single 12,000 ton per year plant
operating in parallel with the earlier
one but instead concerned about assured
continuity of operations they insisted
on three more 4,000 port ton units in
parallel I'll never forget seeing for
4000 ton units one side by side inside a
very large brick building operating in
the later part of the 50s using our
technology but the Germans soon learned
from us and others and soon adopted many
of the American practices and deployed
American engineering chemical
engineering design just like everybody
else
our conclusions from this period the
first 20 years that I've described or
something along these lines the world
was now the marketplace for industrial
companies the risks of moving abroad and
those that era were low secondly
patented exclusive technical advantages
are critical and our industry they most
certainly are in our form of capital but
the diffusion of technologies extry
increasingly rapid and competition
restricts profitability third chemical
engineers pursuit participating directly
in the laboratory with chemists and
frequent interchange between laboratory
the design room plants start-up and the
like provide an integrating force and I
use this word in a somewhat different
context from what was used before lunch
that Spurs commercially valuable
innovation in the shortest possible time
by applying the latest fundamental
principles aided by computers we design
large scale plants directly from a micro
pilot plant and we could the speed
commercialization of new technology and
gain an important position in the
marketplace fourthly as CEO who was
technically sophisticated is the key to
successful integration of technology
with company strategy other
technologically based industries have
also been learning this lesson some more
slowly than others fifthly the
commercial applicability of an invention
often priests
the underlying science I wanted to
comment briefly on an earlier discussion
that showed a model of science
inventions its innovation and so on down
to the marketplace we published the
article in our and a book that I wrote
with Nate rosenberger Stanford several
years ago on the way innovation really
takes place in industry which we call
the chain link model if you have a
chance to read the chapter by Steve
Kline and Nate Rosenberg it'll show you
how much more complex the real
industrial process of innovation is many
of our and sixth a process improvement
is a major opportunity to gain
profitability many of our developers are
by no means breakthroughs but they
contributed continuous productivity
improvements in cost advantages because
in this era many companies focus the
research efforts on new products we and
other design firms were able to
demonstrate the great benefits of
continuing process innovation seventh
research efforts were almost entirely
market driven and the federal government
had no significant share in the
industry's work this era ended about the
middle 60s with the arrival of Vietnam
War the Great Society and the
full-fledged recovery of the major
competitors abroad for our own company
became very clear reliance a worldwide
licensing and building could not be
sustained and self manufacture became
more urgent now we enter what I call the
turbulent period of 1966 to 1981 I'm
sure many of you remember that very well
from about 1966 americans annual
productivity improvement started to slow
down and collapse by 1973 the
merchandise trade balance also started
to deteriorate by 1972 the real trade
balance became negative all of the
nominal trade bound did not sink into
the red until 1981 some industries were
affected more than others the first
slide
we'll show that only three of the
research intensive industries or
high-tech industries of you will have
had consistent positive trade balances
aerospace chemicals and scientific
apparatus and the Green Line with a
little symbol of a chemical plant is of
course our chemical industry other
industries started down early especially
petroleum after the 1973 oil shock which
I show in slide to the petroleum in this
case is shown with a a Derrick as you
can see
American competitiveness and world
markets have begun a long term erosion
Vietnam expereince Kannamma policy and
it had powerful lasting effects on the
world economy firstly you have the slide
off now a great demand overstimulation
took place inflation and rising in trace
interest rates appeared there was a
structural budget deficit
there was a sharply declining dollar in
the early seventies in the United States
abandoned the Bretton Woods regime of
fixed monetary exchange rates in 1971 a
significant flow of the savings pool of
the United States into less productive
residential and commercial construction
took place as investors fled from
financial to real assets in order to
protect their capital and of course the
cost of capital rose there was a decline
in capital investment per worker as the
baby boom peaked and hence there was the
decline of productivity gains in the
1980s there has been some improvement
particularly in manufacturing Japan the
two to three times as much annual
capital investment per worker had a high
productivity gain but the United States
created a large number of jobs mostly in
small companies unlike Europe or
unemployment arose in the face of many
new entrants jobs became an important
part of United States economic policies
in that era there were two massive oil
price increases in 73 and 79 which
siphoned enormous wealth out of the
industry
world there was a rise of the
environmental movement resulting in much
greater regulation and litigation
businesses were required to invest large
sums that clean up the excesses of many
years in the past and to do it pretty
quickly volatility of economic
conditions appeared as a regular feature
and myopic planning horizons for
business accompany them and the
intolerance of the ravaging effects of
the inflation of the 1970s resulted in
Jimmy Carter's appointing Paul Volcker
as chairman of the Federal Reserve Board
to subdue it in 1979 and that of course
resulted in the recession of 81 to 82
which marked the end of what I call the
turbulent period now the chemical
industry needless to say was very
strongly affected by these immensely
climatic changes firstly in the shorter
run inflation and the war provided a
large demand stimulus which was misread
by many companies as indicating a larger
potential market than actually existed
this led the much overbuilding
especially of large world scale plants
which each company thought would give it
the advantages of scale only to be
dismayed as other companies rushed in
with equally large facilities the notion
of optimum scale expanded over time
aided by the very skills of the chemical
engineers involved who learned how to
design and build ever large got larger
single train plants it was not until
market conditions prevented operational
capacity that it became evident that
smaller plants operating at full
capacity could be more profitable big
plants operating at half capacity
economists have recently pointed out in
fact that American management's in fact
invested more than financial
considerations alone would have
justified in the last fifteen to twenty
years and that was part of what lay
behind that secondly profitability
dropped significantly as is shown in the
next two slides slide three shows the
profit margin in terms of percent of
sales for the chemical industry which is
marked in green and the operating rate
which is marked in orange and while the
scale is relatively compressed I think
you can see that when an operating
margin in 1985 for example dropped down
the
over 4% the industry's not doing well
and it pretty much tracks the capacity
factor as well although not by any means
one on one that the slide next slide
shows a slightly different measure of
profitability of the industry as a whole
it's the return on assets in percent
also with a operating rate in orange and
the return in green as you can see the
return on assets also has gone from a
high of over 10% in 1973 to a low of
just over 4% in 1985 we've had a very
violently fluctuating history during
this period now I turn this light off
please
management's found financial conditions
in a near arising inflation to be
critical to survival while technologist
was still prevalent in this industry
MBAs and financial officers also became
indispensable for all the foreign
competition aided by extensive licensing
I've described before is now very large
the United States chemical industry
still enjoyed scale factor cheaper
resources the best chemical engineering
the world substantial technological
edges in many areas and international
presence and our trade balance remain
positive as it has to this day
fifthly entry costs were becoming even
greater only the large companies could
now play however the oil companies move
forcefully into the already crowded and
overbilled arena six lay many of the new
technologies of the 40s and 50s were now
being fully exploited to reduce costs
raise quality and diversify product
lines so at the step back just a moment
it was only after the war that the
immense new markets and large-scale
demand produced the great surge in
petrochemical development and also in
the demand for chemical engineers some
scholars have incorrectly contended that
the innovative urge of the industry
declined decade by decade it hasn't but
it has changed in its character until
the middle 60s or so major
commercialization was accomplished for
important young plastics and for the new
fibers each required low-cost feedstocks
from the large new olefin and aromatics
plants also a large segment that the
innovations made during this period
included significant process
improvements for precursors of plastics
developed
earlier years after 1966 the tonnage
plastics already in place became ever
more differentiated more sophisticated
in fibers and plastics such as kevlar
and composites were begun additional
precursor process developments were
previously commercialized polymers were
introduced several involve switches and
raw materials as the energy price shocks
were seen to be permanent in the more
recent years innovative developments
continue to focus on further product
differentiation and adaptation of lower
cost processes for precursors the oil
and process engineering firms also did
much innovating as did foreign companies
because of vigorous international
technological competition among chemical
and oil companies companies everywhere
could commercialize innovation made
elsewhere virtually all products were
very large tonnage which provided an
economic basis for innovation and hence
for the talents of chemical engineers
grounded in design but there was there
was much new chemistry also in close
cooperation between chemists and
chemical engineers by the end of the
1960's that depressed earnings of the
industry were reflected in the discount
to market of chemical equities in the
early nineteen seventies returns on
capital had dropped to a level where
differentiated producers could support
new investments while most others could
not
optimism dropped after 76 when many
companies finally realized that growth
in the industry which had been at least
twice that of the GNP to this point had
slowed grows margins and the commodities
had disappeared and the increases in
hydrocarbon prices would have a negative
effect on future earnings unfortunately
much new capital had been committed to
the commodity sectors partially because
of the large client syndrome and
partially because of the ease of
adoption of new technology with a me-too
attitude which was rather a cocky
expression of hitherto successful
operations many judgments about future
markets turned out to be mostly in error
hence in the absence of large new
capital investment possibilities
chemical companies turned to increasing
R&D the eight chemical industry proved
particularly vulnerable in the
public sighs - environmental and
toxicity hazards some companies were
spending up to 1/4 of their capital on
such investments in inhibiting other
kinds of innovation for our company our
agreement with Arco permitted us to move
rapidly abroad to Rotterdam to Japan and
to Spain from a zero share the market we
roast and not far from half and
introduce some new products also by not
copying other companies but and
technology but striking out boldly with
new and riskier technology we
established a dominant enough position
to benefit most fully from future
exploitation and descend down a rapid
learning curve by 1980 however the
traumatic events in the general economy
that I have been describing could no
longer be overcome even by all the
advantages we had that I have cited
above the prime interest rate in the
winter of 1979 to 1980 rose to 21% at
that point our share and our ventures
cash flow was going solely to the banks
the time horizon the management was very
short indeed it was the next quarterly
payment of interest we were forced to
sell out to our Co and after the
recession of 1981 and 82 I sold the rest
of my company and I became an academic
economist so that I could find out why
all this had been happening to us at the
height of our success
now I'll sketch in the present era which
I think you all know just as well as I
do if not better than 81 onward the
Vietnam experience cry bitterly was
succeeded by what might best be called
Carter AMEX Reaganomics because it
started with Volcker in 79 and has
continued to this day
inflation followed by deflation a sharp
recession occurred in 81 82 followed by
about six years of uninterrupted growth
some revival of gains and productivity
which had about three and a half percent
manufacturing some marginal tax rate
cuts and growing budget deficits but the
still high real interest rates combined
with the need that financed the budget
deficits created by a strong
international demand for dollars and the
dot and the dollar appreciated to where
many exports became uncompetitive and
imports cheap the current account
deficit grew to the present - three and
a half percent of GNP reflecting the
inflow of 160 billion dollars for
investment in the United States in 1987
American Savings & Investment declined
relative to the Japanese investment
folded because industry was suffering
from the overcapacity the 70s rapid
technological change and the trade
imbalance induced heavy competition for
American companies not only in
international markets but also
domestically the huge debt created by
the government and the private sector
moved first into the financial markets
rather than into the real world of goods
and services this and the tax code which
permits deductibility of interest on
debt but not dividends on equities are
among the primary factors that lay
behind the junk bonds corporate
takeovers leveraged buyouts
and other creative financial
manipulations a high interest rates and
cost of capital contributed to short
term horizons well it's true that some
bad management's were driven out by this
process the general atmosphere of fear
in many companies also reduced
propensity for risk-taking as a dollar
weakened by the middle 80s exports in
the United States improved but also
encouraged foreign companies to buy
assets in this country beginning in some
cases as early as 76 to 77 chemical
companies did respond to their external
pressure
successful survivors needed a rapid
improvement in their processes high
yields were essential for expensive raw
materials and high energy costs
necessitated efficient heat conservation
the chemical engineers talents were
indispensable from this year as well the
new arco propylene oxide plant in France
for example using our technology
operates on any external heat energy
source at all under normal operating
conditions because many like these
advantages by late 1982 several major
chemical company stocks sold at the same
absolute stock level of 1959 investors
saw these companies as mature commodity
manufacturers threatened by new sources
of low-cost production in Canada the
Middle East and so on this
underestimated the degree of change a
renewed innovation that already taken
place and the future potential even in
the year of 1982 although many major
areas weren't profitable the specialty
businesses of some companies contributed
a large share of the profits although
accounting for only a small fraction of
their sales and assets the productivity
declines and here I refer to
multi-factor productivity shown in the
next slide for the chemicals the the
productivity index is shown in yellow
and the capacity operating rate again is
shown in orange suggests the extent of
restructuring going on and the decline
and therefore it's very clearly points
to a decline in capital productivity
during this period capacity utilization
being obviously very critical when did
the better demand environment opinion
turn this light off in 1983 the net
result of such constructive changes was
a rapid buildup of cash from 1986 on the
industries benefiting from lower oil
prices a weaker dollar and growth in the
world economies its restructuring as
resulted in emphasizing its lack of
labor intensive 'ti its total employment
of slightly over 1 million has hardly
changed in over 10 years during which
total sales nearly doubled so that in
real terms labor productivity after
being essentially flat from 1973 to 81
has been improving rapidly by almost 50%
since that
time.this cash flow has been used to buy
back stock and race stock prices and we
expanded in new areas promising future
growth and increased related R&D
expenditures capital investment and
modernization rationalization a major
commodity manufacturer and finally some
new capacity in certain sectors such as
plastics people still remember being
burned by over capacity as you can
imagine and an export-led drive for a
new capacity as a tenuous thing these
days the chemical industry today
combines a large commodity based capital
intensive substructure the proprietary
research based overlay these businesses
require different skills but this
combination defines the competitive
companies of the future in many ways we
are now in a golden age of American
chemical manufacturer few industries are
so thoroughly pervaded by strategic and
tactical issues involving product
Geographic and customer diversification
forward and backward integration
technology advances economic and
non-economic competitors international
financial structure environment and
safety questions capital marketing and
research intensity it supports probably
the world's largest privately financed
research and development budget and and
it also is the strongest individual
industry in Europe and the Europeans
have a trade balance at 27 billion
dollar surplus and chemicals alone the
next slide shows the expenditures for
R&D as a percent of scale of sales for
the research intensive industries of
course this isn't terribly meaningful
since in some cases like instruments or
aerospace it's a very large component of
their sales on our industries
nevertheless quite a high performer in
this area and the next slide shows the
current are in the expenditure table
with an indication of where the funding
is coming from and as you can see the
funding of the chemical industry is
essentially 97% privately funded as
contrastive at aerospace which is 80%
government funded this is not the place
to discuss the very different histories
and characteristics of these two very
successful companies
industries but you can see there already
that there are some very profound
differences in explaining them certainly
Rd alone is not enough to account for
positive trade balances industries that
are successful in trade have a number of
the favorable factors I've been
describing the rapidly changing quality
indices product is not reflected in
these productivity figures certainly
many fibres plastics consumer products
and so on are much better are more
diversified thus I have to look at
profitability and the international
competitive position as indicators of
the health of the industry at present
our industry is operating close to 100%
of realistic capacity nevertheless the
rapid pace of global technology will
necessitate replacement of obsolete
facilities and yet in spite of its
technical accomplishments which are
immense the industry over the past
thirty years has not been able as you've
seen to establish sustained high
profitability foreign large buyers may
yet raise their ownership of America's
industry to a much higher level in the
past three years approximately one third
of foreign investment in manufacturing
the United States has come into the
chemical industry and it probably is
about 25 percent far known today it may
well be that there should be some
mergers in this industry to fend off
such takeovers by foreigners some of our
chemical companies are too small to stay
in the race one should take as a
cautionary note that the American
dyestuffs industry is now 100% foreign
owned now let me dwell very briefly and
my concluding remarks about the future
nearly everyone thinks the domestic and
world recession will come sooner or
later our deficits may diminish oil
prices are uncertain but domestic oil
production is clearly shrinking there's
talk of yet more tax bills a new
administration may take office of a few
commitments and no one knows exactly how
to increase the savings and investment
rate of American society and companies
needed to catch up with the many more
modern installations abroad when hurdle
rates for new investments are 15 to 20
percent in the United States and perhaps
five to eight percent in Japan where
capital costs only 1% it can be seen how
big our capital problem really is and
this is especially true in financing
research in the
development which is at all equity
financing the chemical industry has
suffered in profitability from
misallocation that capital dover large
commodity type plants for quite a while
given a reasonable macroeconomic climate
the american chemical industry will
survive and grow and will certainly
participate in the newer fields of
materials electronics manufacture
biotechnology complete systems including
fabricated equipment and instruments and
so on as well as an extending and
deepening its own traditional products
take the last slide off please
it may well become the world's leading
industry in the 1990s and one of
Chemical Engineering there are some
disturbing signs college enrollments are
down many more fields attract the best
students as well as ours spreading them
more thinly chemical and oil company
expansions are fewer companies feel they
need talents different from those of the
typical undergraduate trained chemical
engineer and you heard about that from
Jimmy way earlier the public sees
chemicals are dangerous there is an
increasing lack of strong industrial
orientation in many chemical engineering
departments a trend that began in the
late 50s as government funding of
university research became dominant and
engineering science moved the discipline
closer to a more academic orientation
perhaps a partial return to a greater
proportion of industrial funding would
be a better balance and here I think we
have at that MIT the National Research
Council's frontiers in chemical
engineering report with Jimmy described
has discussed many aspects of this
question including a forecast at even
closer integration of process design
product development and market needs in
the newer areas will represent the
product opportunities of the future and
that that there be no mistake the new
specialty of differentiated chemicals
require continuously operating plants in
many many instances and they need to be
designed properly chemical engineers are
therefore stress their scale-up ability
but in relation to both flexibility and
economic considerations if we cannot
convey this ability to serve as leaders
of a team having this focus we risk the
loss of identification and the
employment contest to chemists
biochemists material scientists etc it
was process design tight
we linked the market demands and
research and development but fueled the
rise at chemical engineering and the
industries with which it has been
associated this model should serve not
only as our paradigm but also is one for
other engineering disciplines which as I
said earlier have not had this tradition
and I've seen the Japanese adopt such a
model for the manufacturer many complex
machines and objects Chemical
Engineering at MIT today is even now
serving as a source of inspiration to
other disciplines recently in connection
with this bold new leadership for
manufacturing initiatives led of course
by Dean Lester Thurow will speak in a
few moments MIT is adopting the model of
our practice school and some essential
features by proposing to establish other
such centers in a variety of
manufacturing plants so that students
and faculty could study the process as a
whole at the same time we must be aware
of the macro environment which shapes us
we are entering a new world of intense
international competition global markets
rapid diffusion of Technology and in
many respects obsolete national domestic
policies which are increasingly
disciplined by the world financial
markets we don't want to build
facilities and conduct research for
unprofitable plants because of
infatuation with the technology while
overlooking the large role that
financial considerations will play in
the next decade in an era of high-cost
capital I have written some articles and
books on this subject but that's not a
proper - theme for today I end as I
think most other speakers have and a
salute my greatest teacher my greatest
inspiration the man who probably had
more to do with the industry and the
professional I've been described as any
other single individual the real father
of our profession Warren K Lewis but I
would be remiss if I didn't say that I
think the present day chemical
engineering department at MIT is once
again in the same magnificent leadership
position that it was in the days when I
was there in the 40s and 50s a great
deal of the success of this is due to
the inspirational leadership of Jimmy
way had the tremendous stars of the
faculty that he has assembled and I feel
very comfortable about the future of
chemical engineering at MIT
as a consequence and I'm extremely
grateful to it for having made it
possible for me to do all these things
that I've been describing thank you very
much indeed
[Applause]